welcome to Tech news briefing for
Thursday April 27th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
the British competition and markets
Authority rejected Microsoft's 75
billion dollar deal to buy Activision
Blizzard Activision of course is the
publisher of games such as Call of Duty
and World of Warcraft and the cma's
ruling is calling into question the
viability of the deal
joining me to discuss this development
is wsj reporter Kim mccrail so Kim one
of the UK Regulators say about why it
rejected this deal their big concern is
with competition in the cloud video
gaming Market which is a relatively
newer Market that's that's growing
quickly not as big as the market for
console gaming so you know gaming on
Xbox Nintendo PlayStation it's a smaller
Market a rapidly growing market and one
where they're concerned that if
Microsoft owns Activision and Activision
is a major maker of very popular games
that that could actually damage
competition in in the cloud video gaming
Market Kim one of the big issues that
was talked about before this decision
came out was the role of the Call of
Duty franchise and whether that would be
available on platforms apart from
Microsoft's Xbox did that come up at all
in the UK regulator's decision yeah it
definitely did so Call of Duty yeah it's
a really really popular game and during
the break regulatory review process
Microsoft said that it signs some
agreements to make a Call of Duty and
other Activision Games available on
other consoles and said that it offered
to to Sony to do that as well and in the
cloud gaming Market as well but uh the
UK regulator it acknowledged that those
those deals were made and that Microsoft
had offered to make commitments to the
regulator to make sure Call of Duty was
available to other service providers but
the CMA the regulator basically said it
doesn't think that goes far enough other
Regulators are still deciding whether to
approve this deal will the UK's decision
influence them at all so not directly
the regulars have their own processes
and it won't change the legal arguments
that they're looking at but it actually
might take some pressure off of the U.S
regulator in particular because
if this block from the UK stays if
Microsoft is not successful in an appeal
then there's kind of less reason for the
US to pursue this case on its own we've
seen the CMA kind of step into this
bigger role in terms of being a
technology Watchdog how did Britain
start to take on this position once
Britain exited from the European Union
the CMA started getting these much
bigger Global deals to look at so in the
past those cases would have been looked
at by the European Union's competition
Watchdog and now increasingly these
cases are being picked up by the CMA
itself and we're seeing the CMA emerge
as really a pretty tough Global
regulator and with this decision is
maybe signaling it could be the toughest
Global regulator
all right then what is this mean for
Microsoft what can it do now
yeah so Microsoft has said it's going to
appeal in this case the bar for an
appeal is is high so with the UK's
system an appeal has to meet a threshold
for judicial review which basically
means that they have to convince the
appeals tribunal that the decision was
irrational or that it didn't follow
proper procedure or that it was illegal
that's quite a high bar and that goes
beyond just trying to say we think you
need to take another look at it can
Microsoft move forward without the UK's
approval yeah that's a really tricky
area it seems at this point it's very
unlikely that it would even try to and
the reason for that is that video gaming
is a global industry the deal is a
global deal and carving out a big market
like the UK is um is not something
that's seen as really practical for the
companies
all right that's wsj reporter Kim
mccrail thanks for joining us Kim
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing for more Tech stories head over
to our website wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas
for The Wall Street Journal thanks for
listening
[Music]